[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la pièce s'appelle vagabondou vagabondou
pour dire un des gens de la rue des gens
comme ça et après moi j'ai choisi de
prendre le le sens éthmologique de de du
du mot vagabondou je pour dire des gens
que qui voyagent des gens que qui qui
qui vend dans le monde en fait cette
pièce il a beaucoup à voir avec la
migration et tout
[Musique]
ça
on est des danseurs traditionnel du coup
comment mettre en valeur notre notre
expérience en tant que danseur et
chorégraphe traditionnel dans le
contexte
[Applaudissements]
d'aujourd'hui il doivent s'écouter et
pour être ensemble parce que comme c'est
beaucoup s les les C rythme que la
musique continue en fait ça ça a pas de
cassure à l'intérieur il doiv s'écouter
le plus
[Musique]
possible toujours cette énergie quand
vous travaillez ensemble cette ambiance
c'est toujours cette énergie qu'on qu'on
essaie de de de
garder
on a on a cherché ça comment développer
une égie ensemble comment être toujours
à l'écoute de l'un et de
[Applaudissements]
l'autre alors on partage la vitalité de
l'océan Indien la vitalité de tous ces
artistes et on va dire aussi leur leur
imaginaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'inspiration cette pièce c'est aussi
une partie de du jouer avec nos
expériences depuis longtemps en fait les
mosambiquains vont en Afrique du Sud
pour pour travailler
et voilà aussi c'est qu'on entend par
rapport à la migration par rapport tous
ces histoires de des gens qui sont
obligés de pas partir
de de leur pays de leur
[Musique]
maison il il y a du mouvement et aussi
moi je me dis quel regard sur la
migration on peut centrer vers le corps
et du coup il y a il y a eu toujours
cette question du
corps et sa présence en fait il pour
trouver sa présence on joue avec le la
voix et le
mouvement et la rencontre avec le public
rignonnais c'est une bonne expérience
c'est marrant hier on discutait de ça je
je me suis dit qu'il y a vraiment une
bonne qualité d'écoute c'est un échange
et là tu sens que tu donnes tu reçois
des trucs par rapport au public du coup
il y a une bonne qualité du
[Musique]
public